please allow me a moment to ranks Sony I
love PlayStation Plus every month you
deliver excellent games that I may have
missed otherwise and all for free it's
an incredible service but I think you've
made a pretty big mistake in Mays lineup
one of the free games this month is pro
evolution soccer 14 a soccer game in
America yeah i'll let this one slide but
don't let it happen again now let's take
a look at the many free games that don't
involve flopping and ball kicking the
big game this month well there's not
really a big one per se so I'll just
start with the PlayStation 4 stick it to
the man continues the streak started in
November with resogun no retail games
have been given away free just yet I
haven't played stick it to the man yet
so I'm happy to get it for no charge
it's just a shame it's not cross by with
the Vita version next up puppeteer
gamespot zone mark walton gave this a
whopping nine point 0 last year that
means it's better than the last of us
all right all joking aside it's full of
whimsy and it's free and no one would
complain about free whimsy would they
then we've got Skullgirls encore I don't
know much about fighting games that
don't include dinosaurs for resident
fisticuffs expert Maxwell McGee says
it's really fun so there you go pretty
fun then we've got to vita games Serge
deluxe is a block linking puzzle game I
haven't tried it yet but getting it for
free could convince me to take a look in
limbo while everyone's played limbo
already the game is almost five years
old but if you somehow haven't it's
excellent so that's it for me let's hope
June's a bit better
you